[الموسيقى]
على الرغم من
خلفيتهم على الرغم من
ثقافتهم ، إلا أنهم يتشاركون في
مطلب واحد مشترك وهو أنهم
وكلابهم عندما يأتون من هذه
الأبواب يتوقعون
أن يكون كلبهم قادرًا على اللعب
هنا
ويكون  المخصب هنا بأمان
والكلب لديه توقع أنه
سيكون لديه جحيم يومًا
سعيدًا ، اعتقدنا
أنه كان هناك الكثير من الكلاب في دبي
ولكن القليل جدًا الذي كنت قادرًا على القيام
به معهم خارج المقود ،
لذا كان حلنا  مساحة كبيرة في
دبي 60.000 قدم مربع 20 ملعب
تنس وقررنا بناء
أه
شيء مميز جدًا لكلاب
دبي في الواقع نحن نجلس هنا
في أكبر
منتزه داخلي للكلاب في العالم
أم أنها تغطي 30000 قدم مربع
ثم نحن  لدينا قسم الإقامة
ورائي والذي يضم 180
جناحًا ،
لدينا صالون تجميل بالطابق العلوي
حيث نقوم بإصلاح أيام الشعر السيئ بشكل جيد ، كل يوم
في حياة كلب في منزلي الثاني هو
أمر مميز جدًا في الواقع.
دق على مدار اليوم
الذي يتم اصطحابهم فيه ،
أفترض أن رحلة تناوب حسية
نقوم بتدويرها من خلال خفة الحركة من خلال
حمامات السباحة الداخلية من خلال حمامات السباحة الخارجية التي
يلعبون بها مع الكلاب من حجمها
ومزاجها
ثم يعودون فقط إلى غرفهم
للنوم وأحيانًا  لتناول الطعام ،
يطلق عليه اسم بيتي الثاني ، كان مناسبًا جدًا ،
لقد أخذها الأشخاص حرفيًا تمامًا ، أنت
تعلم أن بعض الأشخاص يريدون الغرفة التي
يوجد بها الكلب لفترة طويلة من الوقت
مزينة مثل غرفتهم في المنزل ،
يحب بعض الكلاب إطعامها ثلاث مرات في
اليوم
العديد من الكلاب لديها أنظمة غذائية خاصة
وصلابة الأنظمة
تجعلك تعلم أنها مقدسة ولا يمكن
التدخل فيها أبدًا والسبب الوحيد الذي
يجعلنا مصرين جدًا على ذلك هو أن
الكلاب تزدهر في بيتي الثانية
بشكل مباشر  نتيجة
الروتين ، يجب على
جميع الكلاب قبل أن تطأ أقدامهم في
المنتجع المرور بها ، لن
أسميها عملية تقييم صارمة
ولكنها شاملة
يتم تقييمها
خلال فترة  شاهد مع أصحابها
لتبدأ حيث نتعلم قليلاً
عن حياتهم ، ثم نجعلهم
يتفاعلون مع اثنين أو ثلاثة
كلاب مختلفة من مزاجات مختلفة ،
ثم نسمح لهم بالتلاعب في المقود
مع كلاب مختلفة ، ثم نجعلهم
يقضون نصف يوم في  رعاية نهارية مع
كلاب
مختلفة وعندما وصلنا إلى نهاية ما
يبدو وكأنه عملية شاقة جدًا ،
فهل نقرر ما إذا كانوا يعتقدون
أنهم سيمرون أو يفشلون أم لا ، لكن
الأهم من ذلك أن هناك الكثير
من الأهمية لكل كلب آخر
يأتي أم لا  هنا لأن هذا هو السبب الذي يجعل
الجميع يتعايشون جيدًا هنا
مع كلاب المستردون وأقوياء البنية في منطقة المسبح في الهواء
الطلق لاستراحة المرحاض